so now that we have inserted the page title we're going to do the page
description right here so just so you know the page description let's say you
were looking for Bentonville concrete is this description right here that comes
up and I'm sure so see how Angie's list right here it says dot dot dot that's
something that we don't want we want everything in the page description to be
able to fit and how you do that is just to keep it's just by keeping the page
description between 160 and 165 characters and again we're going to use
the word counter page descriptions are very easy to do you're just pretty much
giving a short brief simple description of what that page is about so for the
home page right here I would probably just and I'm just going to type it in
here so I know exactly when I'm hitting that 160 character mark I would say
Queen Creek concrete offers all types of concrete services whether whether you
need a driveway or patio installed
give us and I like to add the phone number in there it's just an extra way
so like see how our website here has the phone number I like doing that
because it's just an extra way of putting your phone number out there it
is not a requirement you can do whatever you want it's just something that we
usually like to do so give us a call at make a phone number and again make sure
it's the correct one the tracking number that we have put everywhere on
our website call us at okay we still have a little bit concrete officer all
type of concrete services both residential and residential and
commercial don't forget it needs to be below 65 so if needed make it shorter
okay I'm just going to copy and paste that in there I usually read through it
again quicker concrete officer all type of concrete services whether you need a
driver or a party install gives a call at okay perfect now let's do the other
pages
are you located in Queen Creek Arizona and need concrete driveway installed
get a free estimate free estimate today by visiting our site or give us a call
that in there okay that was actually for the driveway so I am going to base it
on my second service page perfect and then let's do the stamped concrete and
I'm going to leave that phone number there so I don't have to keep copying
and pasting it and I'm going to say stamped concrete is a great great way to
get the stone
the natural stone texture and look while having the
Pros and Strength of Concrete for a Free Quilt Colors Act.
The stamped concrete is a great way to get the natural stone texture and look while having
the pros and strength of concrete for a free quilt.
And don't overthink it.
I mean, as long as you sound professional and it sounds like it's explanatory of the
page that you're writing about and you're keeping it below 165 character, that is really
all you need to do.
And then for our last one, for the patio, concrete patios are a great way to create
a new outdoor space for your home.
Get a free estimate today.
Call our experts at new contractors.
Yeah, we can even put Queen Creek.
That way we put the location in it.
Okay, we're going to copy that.
There you go.
And you're done because we don't do a page description for the contact page.
One thing that we want to do for the contact page is right here, if you go into SEO settings,
just have a look at the page description.
And then after you're done as everything else that we've been doing, make sure you publish
it to save it.
And that is it.